des mots d'ici démo de là-bas à la
commanderie on ne parlait que d'eux les
mots ont eu leur premier village
entièrement dédié ce week-end le mode
c'est d'abord la communication c'est une
manière entre nous de communiquer mais
le mot quel qu'il soit je veux dire que
ce soit de notre langue ou d'autres
langues
il est important et je pense important
de savoir quels mots choisir le poids du
monde il est essentiel de choisir le bon
mot au bon moment plutôt que d'entendre
d un peu tout et n'importe quoi au
niveau du langage deux jours pour
développer la créativité sans compter en
yvelines avait invité conférencière
orthophoniste poète et calligraphe le
mot c'est ce qui constitue pour nous la
poésie la calligraphe et le mot composé
de plusieurs lettres
donc nous on apprend quand on commence
notre apprentissage
on commence par la lettre les justement
dans les démarches de l'apprentissage la
lettre tout seul la lettre est attachée
et le mot donc c'est vraiment notre et
dernière étape la place du mot n'était
pas n'importe laquelle dans une phrase
il fallait que le mot tombe bien qu'ils
aient le dernier mot et éventuellement
l'amour la langue française partagez la
langue française qui est plein de
ressources
plein de mots avec lesquels on peut
jongler donc
raymond avait l'art de mettre le mot là
où il fallait pour que ce soit le petit
grain de sable qui dérègle la mécanique
le village du mot clôturer le printemps
des poètes une vingtaine de rendez-vous
était programmé autour d'un thème celui
de la beauté